how's it going press my name is beatta
today we're going to do what everyone
did back in 2015
eat candy and react to it
scorch box send me one of their
exclusive packages of their finest candy
and it's all Japanese candy I asked them
to send me to the weirdest [ __ ] they
could find so none of these have English
labels so it could literally be anything
there's a fish on this one so I'm gonna
assume what are you doing what don't you
[ __ ] understand what are you doing
what do you think's a weirdo in front of
me like what like this in the background
what this was hot but other than that I
don't know what it is could be tentacles
if oh wait probably is actually look at
that I'm gonna eat it and I'm gonna
guess what it is right now live on the
papaya Channel
this one is opened
so that's I'll leave that pack of
condoms this could be a man's urine for
all I know
each time I guess what it is I could win
ten pounds brad has the faucet what does
it call when you have the right answer
sheet you don't have a word for it okay
we're gonna start with this one do you
that does not smell good
oh this is squid this is squid this is
literally squid oh oh it's soft
I'll hold it
good oh man it tastes so bad so
disgusting yeah it's it's spicy squid
what the [ __ ] are you
I get some pounds thank you okay
this could be really anything I can't
guess what this is what is this I really
can't I can't
oh there son
my tongue hurts
I mean pain don't you go through the
pain it's actually pretty good
all right this is sour balls sour balls
raspberry it is super sour lemon lemon
can I get 20 pounds sterling thank you
very much I'm gonna take Marseille out
okay
next we got matcha flavored croissant
they look pretty interesting mine still
loves matcha so I'm gonna assume this
are not that bad ooh they smell they
smell like licorice
what that [ __ ] is this this is so weird
I can't tell you if I hate it or I like
it okay tell me what this tastes like
oh boy it tastes so good
I think it's green tea fields green tea
is the green tea oh ten years thank you
another one for the bang Pepsi Sakura
flavour what is Sakura flavour cherry
flavor I will tie and find out
yeah it's cherry flavored Pepsi thank
you alright so next up we have this
thing that's opened I have a strong
feeling I should not eat this I think
what is this it's not bad what am i
eating what is this I don't know I can
tell you fish flavored potato fish skin
yeah that's why I say thank you yeah
they've been open you're eating no I got
it next up we have the condoms this is
soy beans I can't tell the flavor it's
good though this is not that weird
well it's free and then fermented beans
20 pounds 25
40 pounds English 20 pounds
congratulations so next up we're gonna
eat this one
I think it's potato chips
this one looks the best so far by far
ooh I'm over here I really like what
Xabi flavor inspire to potato chip ten
pounds thank you wow that was right
right there good boy I better wash that
[ __ ] down with this drink yes this is
how we do it
boom Japan I like your style
oh that smells like ass what the [ __ ] is
this it's curry this curry soda correct
it's Indian curry flavored ramune soda
congratulation thank you thank you very
much
hello darkness my old friend oh we got
the best for last guys the toilet candy
I can't believe Japan would do something
so crazy
whoa what that what the [ __ ] is it what
oh dude I know what this is
I saw this on YouTube what this looks
like an iPhone charger first of all you
got to build your toilet which is not as
easy as people like so you know this is
gonna be so [ __ ] good
probably save the best for the last cuz
this is gonna be so [ __ ] cool all
right toilet done all right three
instructions of course that it's simple
tore the bulb decorate the toilet all
the stickers choose a flavored powder
wait wait wait I haven't not decorated
with stickers gonna put the Eiffel Tower
on mine and I got to put the ice there
sorry next step please wait wishes in
Chinese mr. tang all right so we're
putting this [ __ ] in the show [ __ ] get
it
it's in guys it goes in here now it's in
there now all right now I know we gotta
put
all right we'll just look at the magic
oh my god it's foaming up do you see
this Brad get in here quick Wow yeah
yeah that's some good [ __ ] missus [ __ ]
up yeah I don't like this one
Japan you is straight-up weird man what
the [ __ ] is this making me drink from a
toilet
what's wrong with you I mix it with the
curry yeah put some curry no I'm not
putting that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm Brad I can't I'm serious oh this
looks great guys good job yes the place
up for 50 euro 50 euro 50 euro
it takes just like Japan thank you very
much okay I am going to buy myself a
trip with Marzia we're gonna go to
Mexico and we'll see you there in our
next vlog thank you so much for watching
this video if you enjoyed leave a like
and I will see you Bros in the next
video hello darkness my old friend this
is my Sailor Moon outfit some good news
for you